fantastic powers legend holds that they
waged a terrible battle near the temple
and that their ghosts still war with one
another
you and i aren't so different i have
great power within me too
the only difference is i have no control
over mine
that sounds troubling it's only happened
a few times in my life
and only when i was in grave danger
something rises up from deep within me
and
well i can't really explain it
you there please help they're going to
kill my friend
thieves are going to kill myself what do
they want with your friend
she's just a farmer's daughter sasha but
she has a relic that the thieves are
after
losing my patience wench i'm sworn to
secrecy
release the girl you actually buy new
fools
you won't get away from us this time
i need fury impossible
this isn't over the rest of the phase
guild
will find you
here's the relic my love you wish to
join me
yes yes you look like you know a lot
about markets
now lead the way
wait relic is a fake
gods i should have known you seem like
you could use a helping hand
and i sure as hell don't want to stay
around here please
tell me that you're not considering this
criminal
proposal
what of your betrothed betrothed
do i look like the marrying kind to you
by the way
my name is lyndon
but the tome say of alaric and this
temple is not encouraging
you must be alaric the guardian uncle
deckard told me of your return
no there have been no yet another myth
you seek entrance to this temple but
only a nephilim can enter
if you will follow me i will raise the
bridge that you may pass
seek two tools
the warriors rest and the crypt of the
ancients
a poll of ancient doom hangs upon these
woods
more fury are these people these
are mongrels ghouls are stronger than
most risen dead
but they gain their fortitude through
horrific means
feasting upon human corpses these
creatures are
least dangerous while eating
[Applause]
[Music]
these flying creatures
i gain new strength
when this is over i could open my own
little inn somewhere
if i live that would fit you well if you
ever want a job
i will consider your credentials you do
me a great honor
foreign
don't worry about me
[Music]
icon
ah
but we find more like that
uh
if the temple is open enter
and defeat the guardians within although
they are my brothers
lonely entertainers
my brothers
no way
your strength rivals that you may enter
our most sacred place
the spirit speaks the truth this was a
good place
i can feel it
the noble human fought away here just to
die
and who is this you know your mother
will soon
share your faith the shard is mine save
this temple with their blood
what did you mean my mother will share
my fate
could my mother be alive after all these
years
she is full of lies do not believe her
and what is the power within you that
she spoke of
this fight was too easy she's toying
with us
we must get back to uncle deckard right
away
our children are born weak and suffer
short lives
the demon nereza promised to restore
their power
but instead turn them into mish we have
the second sword i remember
that must be worse ah brilliant